[Music]
in Zombie spiders
News know why you know a zombie spiders
spiders are scary yeah but you don't
kill them though so you're not that
you're not that scared of them
spiders that don't die well find out
would that be submitted by tap pack a
newly discovered wasp turn spiders into
zombies oh [ __ ] Oh might be just
straight by them and then the the
spiders they go no Cole I thought this
was already in a theme have you gotten
beaten by one stung by a wasp that stung
by wasps yeah as a kid you don't
actually get stung by wasps you get by
you whatever whatever did it stop it
stung her there's a stinger and then one
bites like a yellowjacket or like a
Hornet they bite your flesh don't they
have a singer you know eat meat dude
unit wasp yeah they [ __ ] meat dude
it's gross no this whole thing about
training spiders into zombies it
according to this article it has been a
known thing but not specifically the way
these newly discovered wasps do it which
the way they do it is that they lay eggs
onto a spider and then that larvae
larvae larvae larvae is the plural so
which ones I Cosima one larvae Barbara
what what there's like dirt it's okay
you should know this about me you can
say larvas there's a lot of larva the
larva starts to take over the spider and
then it causes this particular spider
which is very if the spiders don't to be
very social there's a lot of friends no
freak dude I'm so kind of colony of ants
then this ant starts to get away from
the colony which is very very strange
for that behavior particular spiders
wait and are spiders she was using
analogy for this okay got it
okay we I said it okay colony is it a
couple times yeah I understood what you
were saying though
to clarify real quick so the hummingbird
comes in and does I thought I'd miss
something I was it the day about the
sorry I don't know it's an ant no we're
only talking about spiders oh okay okay
okay well my auntie Christina now
because I'm so [ __ ] what's going on
yeah makes great food they calling me so
I don't maybe my mind was like what
happened this was transforms a very
social spider into a zombie like drone
that abandoned abandoned its colony were
social creatures that was alone yeah we
see one well according to this
particular spider all I see this
particular one is a very social type of
space portal web or he has a way he does
and so he starts to creating this
specific cocoon that it's very out of
character for this spider
so the larva is controlling it the
larvas controlling the spider the larva
from Hawaii
that's insane dude explain I'm sorry
guys that's dope cuz it's like infecting
a virus in that one spider yeah
programming it to do something and in
building a house for the kid that's like
Borg the Borg from Star Trek coming him
into their mind state that's like
computers this is all I'm a wasp or got
no [ __ ] that reference in a while
dude what the Borg yeah it's from a Star
Trek world
they're like the the race of they're
like half robotic and a half human but
they're like they all have the same mind
state you know it's like the same
collective mind yeah the collective mind
it's like a hive mind state so it like
they can infect like remember when the
card got caught became aboard that one
episode yeah yeah that's why I don't
know why I don't know how what it has to
do with the wasp oh yeah I'm saying it
turns them into their what they want
watch the the Star Trek with the the
female captain which ones that it's next
generation the last one I ever saw
because my mom was so into it was on
with William Shatner and then after then
on my dishes
there's Captain Picard after that and
the holds the I remember that because
the Reading Rainbow guy was there too
there's that levar Carter brunette she's
got brown hair right yeah so the next
generation they had a female captain and
she was you're thinking about the
Klingon dude yeah that's the one with
Captain Picard no that is Star Trek so
they had that and there's like next
generation and there's also there's a
one where they had a newer one when I
was like about 14 or something in that
[ __ ] was dope cuz they had a girl named
seven of nine and she was a Borg and
then she converted back into regular
humanity how did she get off the Borg
Tim I don't know what happened I can't
remember but she wore this like [ __ ]
shiny tight-ass suit you pervert
she was bad as [ __ ] look it up right now
put seven of nine and you see she all
right I think we're all right no I'm
gonna send it to you later on my Google
it went from a wasp historian bubbles
bra no I'm I said if you want a green
bubble later don't worry about it no
you're blocked already no I'm not well
there's a lot of spiders it's time to
play whack-a-mole no it's time to run
and freaking pray to God that should
scary in order for you to kill like
those insects or flies a lot of people
can't catch flies because they're
actually trying to catch it what you
have to do is attack the fly as if
you're trying to go through the [ __ ]
table that's how it doesn't go oh yeah
go fast
exactly so cuz people respond you don't
retract you go all the way the [ __ ]
through and then you'll always try to
break our hand but that's how you always
catch the flight how do you know that
because I like catching flies
it's my skin you do it like mr. Miyagi
style oh no no I could do it if it's out
of service a hundred percent of time
I'll get it with your hand you can kill
it not good I'll kill it
really because people are trying to
catch it so you retract right the last
end and because you [ __ ] out at the end
that's when they get away oh oh you
better go through it like you turn upon
many people [ __ ] huh cuz they don't
want to feel the [ __ ] crunch I don't
give a [ __ ] because the work feeling on
earth is when you here we are [ __ ]
sleeping - yeah and it's next to your
ears you're like God you know what you
got to do if you're sleeping and it's in
your room you turn off all the lights in
your room and it follows light so there
in your hallway or something in Italy
but you still have to catch it though
it's still in the house I mean you can
keep doing that you could leave your
door open and it's gone why do they come
to your face I don't understand did you
have stinky breath your face it never
comes up to my face then why did what
did that come from
you say it comes up to your face come to
my face my [ __ ] nastiest thing have
you ever seen a [ __ ] that's just covered
in all flies oh I did you walk up and go
see disperses I [ __ ] saw that the
other day I [ __ ] freaked the [ __ ] out
I forgot what the cloud of gnats are
just floating there before you guys ever
see like a spider like egg or some [ __ ]
oh and then you [ __ ] pop it in this
video just looking on it you popped it
yeah you know think you know what is
then pop it off the colony you're like
ah dude I know this has nothing to do
with anything but I wanted to tell you I
was gonna Texas the other day but I
didn't text it because I was a little
too long so I found out the type of
human being I am so I had a with his
weird ass spider [ __ ] vivid rod was
driving us around in a van I don't know
how that happened but somehow that van
turned into your old [ __ ] Tahoe or
whatever was it the brown one there the
brown right and I was driving it and I
was dropping you off at home right and
this is a dream and this is kind of like
imagine like East LA like it's a little
like all like these crack streets and I
have dropped you off somewhere as we're
driving a [ __ ] power line comes down
and this power line comes down and I go
over and all the tires pop so we got out
the car and I was walking you to your
house right and as I'm walking to your
house we saw this like this really weird
shanty ass home with like this rusted
like gain around it we decided to go in
when we go into that place we look
around to start the door behind us
closed and when we turn around the whole
room changes so we can't escape we go in
you see you see something in a bathroom
that's so disgusting you actually start
throwing up in there yeah we turn around
again the room changes again and it gets
[ __ ] pitch-black freaked the [ __ ] out
we find a light we start running out
right as we're running out I [ __ ]
bust open the window for us I jump out
first you're coming in and you go wait
for me and also boom you disappear oh I
look up I go she's dead
[Laughter]
I woke up laughing so hard because in
the dream i legit said this I go she's
dead hesitation I left you so fast dude
and you know it's the scary thing about
that we're gonna eat in a pitch-black
place tonight oh really
yeah that's the scary thing about that
all right
are you coming mmm that's so [ __ ]
hilarious huh I guess he's not you'd add
a pitch by first I had a dream about a
Chevy Tahoe - it was a black Chevy Tahoe
and it transformed into a black French
Bulldog and I had government secrets in
the trunk because I was being chased oh
and then when I got out of the car and
parked it I went and it turned into a
little French Bulldog is it the same dog
for a minute black no it's Stephanie's
dog
Stephanie a Souls dog I've never seen
her no it's a French Bulldog it's kind
of like a pug dream interpretation to
dream attack and then David citizen and
I was walking with the the pug I mean
the the Bulldog and then all of a sudden
I'm in an interrogation room and they're
like tell us where you hid it
and I'm like she'll never gonna find it
damn sassy French Bulldog was sitting
there and the whole time it was in its
belly and I was like that's right I see
that's how gangster you are I [ __ ]
left you so fast today the thing that
made me laugh the most was the fact I
said she's dead why did I say that out
loud that shouldn't had me dying but the
weird part about that I just don't know
why I said that in the dream was she's
dead cuz he wanted to leave her ass the
whole she's dead and I just jetted right
but the weird part the creepiest part
about this dream was as I started
leaving like the whole world started
warping and everything's heard of sepia
for a second I want to flip I was like
in like the 1920s it's so slow that all
the cards were old and they were like
those old then I pull up and be like
what's up [ __ ] oh and as I was there
like I was like where the [ __ ] am I and
I clearly stick out and everybody's
staring at me because I'm wearing like
modern clothes not because you're the
only Asian guy like that to see right no
but then I just sat there and I was like
freaking the [ __ ] out and I try to go
back to that house cuz now I had to make
a choice as well I could either stay in
this time I go back to the house and go
back to my own country time travel dude
I just started thinking about what I
wanted to invest into so I could set up
my future then it became a little bit
too practical a dream to me that I don't
know my dreams are very vivid I can
remember my dreams really well too which
is kind of cool
[Music]